preparations for CES are already
underway take a look behind me this sign
is pretty hard to miss if you're driving
down convention center but it's also a
sign that this town is getting ready for
a big economic boom
beyond the cool new gadgets apps and
tools the Consumer Electronics Show
brings in a massive presence from people
all over the globe it's all about
exposure ultimately right yeah uh
getting your word out about what exists
and almost there's a lot of startups
Joshua Levitt is the CEO of tech alley
his non-profit helps Network numerous
startups in the Las Vegas area and an
iconic Tech show like CES could mean a
breakthrough for companies like his I'd
like to see the new technology that's
out there right the new ideas the new
the new products get a direction of
where things are going I think that's uh
that's important especially as you're
trying to you know compete or or stay
stay at least up with the Curve when it
comes to Technologies before the
pandemic put a pause on big events CES
would bring in nearly hundreds of
thousands of people who contributed
millions of dollars to our economy and
2021 CES went to Virtual then last year
only 40 000 people attended we can get
about 700 cars on the slot I think we
had 40 cars 50 cars a day and it was all
exhibitors we caught up with Lorenzo
dumani he owns the property right across
the convention center he says he is
looking forward to seeing his lot full
again but I think what it's going to do
for Vegas to really get the town going
again post covet
[Music]
we don't have the final number of how
many
140 different countries will be there
CES starts January 5th Victoria zaha 8
News Now